what's up how's everyone doing Mike and
I are right here I'm Jake and we're
about to play some battleground some
player unknown battlegrounds I have a
gaming laptop here he's playing on a PC
so we're gonna try to play together if
you guys have any questions you want to
ask this is my sick character you can
see right here yeah Mike's characters
multiple Dom it's not even on there I'm
gonna go to the game oh [ __ ] yeah
multiple tactical advantages hair like
this so it just encouraged me to get a
helmet all that faster to stuff my afro
into it at the earliest chance you want
to jump right in yeah let's get started
probably in a stream for like an hour
today we're doing duo's right now we
were gonna play with a couple other
people in the office but we didn't
really setup discord or anything
beforehand or didn't want to rely on the
voice chat here yeah and yeah we should
be getting a chicken dinner so uh yeah
disclaimer I'm actually not a disclaimer
I think we've both you've gotten like
what three total I've gotten two I've
gotten three I've never done a solo and
you just did what yesterday yeah two on
duo's and one in solo I'm also putting
in headphones because I need to be able
to hear as well my question is why are
you late uh-oh
technical difficulties only two minutes
though and we'll make up for that mm-hmm
microwave chicken nuggets will do
um yes it is my character tobias if any
of the levels are too loud let us know
like if our voices are too loud of the
game place too loud unfortunately we
won't be cutting to my feed we're just
gonna be checking out Mike's eat he's
better than me anyway so it's probably
and then you get more you get more wins
than I have I think I think I panic wow
it's really loud
I'll turn it down more um yeah but no no
I just I actually have a condition where
I cannot feel panic or fear which helps
uh the people want to know Mike what's
your favorite cake what's my favorite
cake yeah I don't really like cake all
that much but I would have to go with uh
I don't know
chocolate I guess alright chocolate ice
cream cake for me that's cheating that's
not cake it's ice cream
I don't care alright so Jake with
ketchup lately the last week or so when
we've been like a couple weeks we've
been dropping into really populated
areas you want to start this off in a
crazy fashion do you want to try to like
get pretty far in our first one cuz I
would say let's go like over here or
something uh even maybe farther like
here okay I'll follow your lead
oh that's kind of far yeah that's the
school about here no no that is this
school oh yeah this is the so let's go
here let's try here for now that looks
like it could be action [ __ ] alright
cheesecake is the best cake but I think
that's pie it's cheese King no I'm
dropping go alright so here's actually
my question I've seen a lot of people
you were telling me you and Michael
there's a few people here we're telling
me that if you flap your arms you go
farther so I saw a video and apparently
because you drop faster though there's
the only thing if you just hold it you
stay at 126 mount kilometers an hour oh
[ __ ] we should just drop anyway we're
here yeah you should be going straight
down alright the people want to know
what your favorite beer is now
oh my favorite beer it is in Minneapolis
actually I'm gonna get kind of hipster
here when I lived in Minneapolis for a
few months I interned up there
is a surly this company they come in
these like 16 oh [ __ ] there's someone
else get that famous Jake Decker
headshot punch in I've been good at
getting headshot we're the team up team
I get it right here
oh [ __ ] there yeah yeah I got I got I
got it oh wait where's buddy hold on
oh [ __ ] sorry sorry sorry I got you
let's hope his friend does not come up
what you laid your first shot oh well
good start sweet all right let's try
that again
all right oh nice nice headshot punch
the spot called us idiots who is that
it's probably Eric dude you you started
us off so well and then I ruined it um
kudos to that second guy for taking the
time to dish headshot me alright I think
that's a good preview wait hold on a
second why can't I get this guy's track
suit coat I've never seen that before in
my life it was taking a while yeah mine
was taking a while too I don't know uh
this person asked why do people like
this game I think it's because it's very
random and it's very tense and it's very
satisfying yeah I mean that was just a
lot of adjectives or a lot of like I
don't know that maybe isn't the perfect
I just taken so on I mean yeah you try
back and I hit the hit that there you go
who knew the refresh button would
actually work alright let's just jump
right back in ya know it's I think it's
the fact that it's uh everybody knows
the rules and they're simple I guess but
uh they're they're tough to actually see
through all the way to the end and it's
yeah it's that randomness it's kind of
like any like this
massive map and your [ __ ] head plot
yeah I'm struggling describe this right
now it's a it's a huge massive map that
you actually kind of it changes every
time you play the map is static but the
actual random drops and stuff are just
kind of change up how you see the map
and how you mess with it but yeah it's
it's just tense like everybody
understands the situation but it's just
kind of funny how it plays out sometimes
like what just happened yeah I mean I
think part of it is because you the life
is so much more precious in this game as
compared to most games like when you
come a court when you're in a firefight
it feels more realistic I guess to
because you're not charging out there
like a [ __ ] because you know that
you're not gonna be able the stakes in
this game are always high no Matt even
if it's really quiet the entire match
until the end or if you're killing like
six people yeah what's your what's your
best kill account from one match do you
know uh first solo I think it's five
four duo's I think it's six yeah is this
only for PC this is only for PC right
now however it is coming to Xbox one for
game preview supposed to be in the fall
and then I think once once the game
fully releases I think they have plans
to bring it to ps4 as well no date
though [ __ ] you guys realize people
depending on how far we get in the match
because of our pit we they won't be able
see how many other people are remaining
oh that is a good point um I forgot
about that I can go to the game no just
hold on go to game yeah we could just do
without a camera I would say do we need
our camera uh no we don't need the
camera necessarily or our uncheck top
right and just do top like uncheck top
right for now we're gonna turn the
camera off because you guys don't really
so yeah you can see yet alright we could
go to the same spot or let's try here
you wanna try that yeah let's do that
in that die right away alright well we
were in good shape until yeah no no past
it alright I drop
is really good all right so I'm gonna do
the swimming thing just because you
insist that it helps or you said there's
a video or something I look forward to
the first person's servers I actually do
- I am Tyrion
what's that hey was asking if he wants
us to move it but I'll be good
want me to move at the bottom left now
we're good
no it's fine well people don't need a so
they apparently there's an update
yesterday where they improve the the
stutter that usually happens with the
cargo plane we're driving in this quarry
I didn't mean to do yeah I guess that's
fine anybody else yep yep there's a
couple people of sweet Oh
so be good oh there's like four people
oh this is gonna be dope should I land
on this roof with this dude I'm I'm
landing on the roof lost my game for a
second with the Destin land on the roof
I'm with this guy oh sure he's got a gun
already [ __ ] I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm
out [ __ ] Jake when you get the chance if
you want to come to help me out oh man I
screwed myself oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I
need to see your face yeah I got a
shotgun and someone wants to see our
face nah we're good for now almost a
really alright I got a shotgun a couple
people here I'm in the I'm in the
three-story building with the roof XS
whoa oh you knock someone out nice and I
am I'm on the cliffs around it cuz I it
went to desktop as I was playing so I
don't know where's buddy is I'm gonna
kill this guy
alright got one I don't know where his
friend is somewhere around here what's
up oh you landed on the cliff sorry I
haven't been listening to anything
you've been see is what I said I wasn't
listening I was kind of busy alright I
don't know I just dude we are so far
from so saying alright whatever let's
make this interesting then I don't know
where this guy's friend is up on the
roof its killer maybe still no there's
no way he'd still be up here right
everything's been cleared out up here
I guess a gas mask are we like what are
we like in a reasonable distance of the
circle or no no oh sick I got a backpack
at least all right well this dudes
friend did not really come help him out
so I'm gonna clear out the rest of these
rooms and try to find something
worthwhile aside from the shotgun Oh
someone else died down here too nothing
all right
hello yeah afro is so dumb yeah it is no
it's not it just makes it encourage me
to get a helmet that much more so I can
oh shoot shootings going on yeah what oh
damn I'm having really bad connection oh
my god dude I'm lagging a lot [ __ ] I'm
down you hear me
yeah his buddies down right next to me
trying to slow yeah I should turn out my
gameplay audio where can you turn out my
gameplay oh yeah oh um okay I'll
spectate you see how far you get I can
look at chat while you're doing this
alright damn that dude had a lot of [ __ ]
I wish you could see the inventory when
they're spectating make it quick so
they're both dead
I need to get out of here though almost
dead give two shotguns yep
cuz I don't have any other weapon this
guy not have a weapon
okay all right yeah get out of here they
didn't have any rifles or anything
no more shotgun so take the five five
six the ammo you got yeah I did there
okay so there usually is a car at the
entrance there's often a car at the
entrance to this place but I'm assuming
somebody took it already Dan that was a
pretty hot zone we dropped into if that
was I was not expecting that many people
yeah it yeah don't worry I've got two
shotguns so should be okay yeah it's
it's a this is the point where wait look
can you uh pull up your map while you're
running if you oh my oh yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah you need a car you got a minute and
a half fish why is it gameplay so low
like well I might have barely hearing
anything there you go you can fit us
your feet slap in the road you're one of
those people that doesn't wear some
boots yeah Dave uh somebody works in our
UK office was saying that I don't know
if it's quieter but it makes a different
sound and for some reason that kind of
it's less just like boots hitting the
ground yeah it's more like slapping yeah
we are assumed we were Justin like North
America West servers yeah yeah I'll
watch the chat you okay I don't want you
to come across someone I do not think I
will come across
yeah let's uh those just joining I got
killed man I don't know if this is our
connection or mine is bad so I'm
watching Jake's laptop for next month
his connection looks fine but this like
my connection looks bad watching you
it's been pretty bad since I dropped
interesting yeah rip it sounds like
people want the PIP no that's just one
person that's a goob we're not we're not
putting the PIP up right now we're not
worried about that
this is on PC I tie 37 it'll be on Xbox
one what sometimes it's fall I think
that's what they said I I heard there
may have been a yeah I mean I this fall
no release date but hopefully soon
because it seems a lot of fun yeah we've
been playing a lot lately we've been
playing more you've been playing more
singles lately I think singles is
actually my personal favorite way I do
like duos there are no freaking vehicles
oh I hear one get their attention no way
there is that a generator no it sounds
like a vehicle it sounds like a buggy oh
there we go nice you got time I mean
it's closing in but you're close enough
I think you'll be fine no we're not I'm
not on Wi-Fi give me a smile so I mean
it looks it probably looks bad right now
what are you doing here oh you try to
get a ride home in a little bit of time
watch someone steal that oh yeah I'm uh
I'm hesitant to ever kind of leave a
house without a some sort of gun decided
shocked and I guess use Resorts your
pistol although I think handguns were
underrated I actually like how easy they
are to control at close range everything
else is kind of built for mid-range
I like the Glock it's a shame I like
never see it though
yeah Michael Fisher I agree this game is
a little more forgiving with four people
I guess that's why I like damn dude my
connections bad it's just it's I mean
part of it is because it's it's not like
your actual instance it's mine no right
I get that but even like before when I
died it was those few seconds before
that I was pretty bad like the guy I've
killed me like two seconds before it
even showed up
I mean server issues are common with
this game anyway this door was open so
I've been wasting my time
dude you're uh it's coming oh that fog
is almost here I think that's one of one
of the things I am decent at this game
is knowing when to just accept that I'm
not gonna get the best inventory and
bail because the circle just becomes you
are good at judging circle time whenever
we play together it's like alright now
this time really going I keep looking at
day like you're not gonna get me perfect
inventory
I don't yeah that I think getting the
perfect inventory is just you have to
accept some you're not gonna
we were
should I stick to the roads and come to
the mountain you could go through Moria
I don't know that's that's a let's see
if you flip this this jeeps actually
pretty stable compared to the other the
other kind you can get the civilian Jeep
which just [ __ ] flips all the time
we've had our fair share of instances
where we go to the school nice is that's
in the circle yeah oh yeah I can pull
out my own map Allah [ __ ] my bad I
forgot it is ok yeah yeah but I mean at
least I get show people's going on go
into this big red thing for a second I
see
yeah go to school what if it just comes
in on Gatka Rick Georgia Pole Jake
you're going right into the bombs right
now what are you two
there's gonna be people here ah yeah I
know yeah flip it flip it
there's a motorcycle back there that'd
be more fun to watch
they know you're there just like a third
of your health oh sorry I don't care
that you could not have made a noisier
entrance yeah
b-boy maestro Jake and I have both I've
had two chicken dinners one in duo's one
in threes not a single but jake has had
a three a two are now two twos and he
just got a solo chicken dinner yesterday
it's on my Twitter yeah I'm gonna go
followed Jacob deck to Kay's on Twitter
if you want to watch it I was like
network leg right in the middle of him
shooting the other last surviving person
Oh baby yeah nice could not have asked
for better
Oh
the circle barely moved you're fine oh
sweet you left to go to the school the
closest building but
Oh
laughter those was joining obviously
this is spectating sorry about the
stutters you're seeing on my screen for
those just joining I died valiantly
earlier you didn't see it and don't
listen anybody else in the chat but it
was it was pretty badass I definitely
didn't get shotgun in the face and I
stare well I killed one person uh and
then in the night and then I I'll admit
I died pretty soon after all right
should I leave oh yeah I heard gunshots
and I heard cars let's uh see what we
can come across you can come across
anybody else
I have never ever ever once picked up
supplies from a Supply Drop I have seen
I don't see the point at that I don't
think Lutz that important most of time
when I'm actually unless I Drive
randomly it dropped it right near me at
the beginning I wouldn't go out of my
way
the only instance I do it is when it is
don't go school I'm going to school it's
good for first aid I would say that
crucial and when you start the game like
if if it's near you it's usually by
chance those windows at least your feet
slapping the ground or just at the
herald of doom for the people in this
building let me ask you this do you like
red dot scopes on handguns because I've
seen you get a kill with it before like
at medium range if I find our gameplay
footage like if I have an extra but I'd
rather have it on a rifle
gube you can have up to four people
total but you can also do squads but
then uncheck wear with this guy what
possibly why did we can't we can't see
your inventory this guy has three red
dot sights and presumably it didn't look
like he had any weapon that he get
attached to did he he just had him in
case he picked I guess you could
theoretically have three weapons that
youth have to be laying around the game
but it's not - I should probably get
that yeah that jump is kind of if you're
not sprinting in this game they really
need to add voltage yeah
yeah I'm saying apparently the update
today like fixed a lot of shitty cargo
planes stuttering at the beginning I say
cargo oh [ __ ] someone's shooting at you
you and I have landed around this area a
number of times and I guess the school
itself is as you can see it's the middle
of the map probably heard stories about
it
pay no attention to this that's nothing
don't worry about it uh this is a solo
game Jake Jake definitely didn't have a
partner earlier that died yeah dude
I wish there were no psycho I were just
like Oh Mike just [ __ ] it go right for
the center go to the swamp towns like
right here and a que si Dan this is a
weird grid I've never looked at that
before it's not numbers and letters just
letters
oh you're going right into it wow that
was awesome
I'm assuming a lot of people to chat
have seen the video of someone ramping
off of the bike and then midair getting
out right next to a balcony where
someone was shooting at them and
shotgunning them in the face
that's so cool I hope in real life yeah
way to go out so check the situation
here how many people 36 alive Oh gunshot
so that's a decent amount of people for
this small of a circle actually that's
not a really small circle bit Oh car I
don't know I heard one
dick let me ask you this if this early
access version what it is now was $60
would you have us stay inside that
doesn't matter your circle would you
have bought it I don't know if I would
have liked I mean that's obviously not
the case that's actually a really unfair
question cuz it's $30 okay
better question more relevant do you
think $30 a good value for this right
now yes I think so I think if if I had
played this before and then like I would
buy it for 60 if I knew how much I'd
enjoy it I'd buy a 60 but at the time
when I was buying this game as I got
there he seems kind of steep for this
yeah I mean the more you play the more
you realize I've never had the same a
similar match twice unless you drop into
like the school for matches in a row if
the flight goes over it but even then
there's still the unpredictability
factor I don't I don't usually like
judging games for their replayability
I think that's kind of overrated a
little bit but in terms of value and
like how random is dude you don't need
it you're in the center I don't know
you're close
I was pretty funny when you and I we
didn't realize that the update had made
doors destructible one was this a few
weeks ago and the bombs or know someone
was like shooting at us when we were in
a shed and all sudden the door started
getting shredded and it's like terrified
us uh yeah people just joining this is a
player unknowns battlegrounds on PC come
to Xbox one supposedly sometimes it's
fall to having really announced the firm
date yet a new map a desert map is in
the works as well as a Mediterranean map
but desert one will be out first a
little bit smaller than this one it's
actually cool if I had it I'd pull it up
but it's a they show like a sketch it's
a lot of like a three a few mid-sized
villages with a lot of shanty towns
outside in an open desert and stuff you
also might want to say why we're playing
battlegrounds oh yeah we Jake and I
actually we both do a show called reboot
it's like an opinion kind of editorial I
don't even know how to describe an
analytic show that we do on every other
Sunday and then on the off weeks we do a
Q&A but we did battlegrounds yesterday
went up if you guys want to go check it
out on GameSpot's youtube channel we
talked about how this game how a lot of
people playing this game kind of have
these crazy stories coming out it out of
it and why this game it's kind of
designed to support that obviously it's
not traditional storytelling it's a
multiplayer game without an actual
narrative but you know we talked about
how you can actually like get your own
story oh this is a different way so go
watch that if you want but yeah our plan
initially for our Monday screams because
Jake and I scream every Monday or try to
one more here we wanted to play whatever
game we talked about extensively on
reboot so that made sense this week but
we also are gonna try streaming this I
think a few weeks out people like it
because I think it's good because but
more specifically people like us to
playing this again if you're just
joining this is a solo match Jake's
partner yeah definitely did not die at
any point right after dropping in ignore
that skull and crossbones there no Jake
is over here near on the outskirts of
Ross shock which you and I have had a
fair number of firefights in before this
is near where we won our first
chicken dinner right yeah our first one
oh man Network lag on my end I was that
your screen that said that anyway it was
my screen I really liked the uzi
actually I didn't - but I the guns I
have right now I don't a switch come on
just kill me someone so we can start a
new game Frank Taylor in the chat just
said he loves to reboot thank you Frank
Oh awesome he's talking about the
probably is most people usually are yeah
this game obviously does not look
fantastic it's early access it's also
the lineage of where it came from is
super interesting and kind of
complicated so alright second I gotta
just this quick it we're back so Brendan
Green was living in Brazil the player
unknown it's his handle he just decided
to make a battle royale mod a la the
movie battle rail or Hunger Games if you
like the lesser of those two and it's
just you know players drop into a set
area with random kind of elements like
loot drops supply drops bombing runs and
I know we weren't talking about emergent
gameplay as much Cuba we have something
else planned with that this is more
about actually rather than the emergence
like how this set rules of this game
kind of supply it but we did mention a
few other games in it if you watch it
you can go check that out but we decided
but but anyway this game started as a
mod for ARMA 2 and then moved to ARMA 3
as a mod start as a dayz mod when that
game came standalone and then it became
more about
I went Sony Online Entertainment before
became daybreak made h1z1 king of the
kill and then they made this standalone
early access but as you can see it's
based off Pharma there you go get some
action I'll kill him
oh wait no oh [ __ ] I know I just
encourage you to shoot him another
another thing that you I think you're
not patient a lot of times for the
stream obviously that was more fun to
watch uh cool I got one I got one kill
let's get back into this let me I got
bored for a while
cool yes we're gonna jump right back out
quick cross play with PC yeah he did
mention that it might that he wants to
be cross play I'm kind of worried about
that though cuz I don't think I play
next masking keyboard yeah
but at the same time like you haven't
been playing mouse and keyboard shooters
that long right this is like your first
real one you're taking into you right
for the most part I mean I've played
single-player ones like I played a lot
of do messing keyboard but like yeah not
multiplayer we are yeah I mean I mean if
you're just jumping into mouse and
keyboard games and you're gonna use a
controller you might have the same edge
as someone else who's just starting with
mouse and keyboard but like in the long
run yeah Mouse is definitely more
responsive for sure yeah
any word on when it is coming to game
preview on Xbox one the last we heard
it's supposed to be in the fall so
hopefully hopefully we'll hear something
soon yeah they haven't heard much more
about it they showed it at e3 obviously
Brendan Green took to the stage well
anywhere like a duster or a trench coat
or something no you guys wearing a suit
yeah I don't know who I'm not sure if
some of us comparing this to the
division I know I see a lot of people
when they're saying it just gets third
person and like a similar aesthetic I
guess - to post apocalypse stuff no this
is more of a
yeah this is multiplier competitive kind
of survival game actually but all right
let's hope my connection picks off this
game I love that yeah division is like
an RPG honestly the missions going more
in the Destiny vein this is its own kind
of sub-genre so I was telling Jake
recently that the first time I got into
a map I thought that was the match and
you start there and then run outward or
grab a gun there so I was competing
unpassable for 16 seconds
yeah what do you want to do it you want
to like first time
what's that what's what you want to be
smart this time and try to drop toward
the center and everything like try to
actually like here or something small
place that might not have a lot of
action or just go to the school again no
all right all right
yeah let's go here one drop three
tonight I just went a lot to do a couple
other guys at least three people or so
we're took marked out I'm looking at the
wrong way I'm not gonna land there I'm
not let's uh let's try to hold on so I
can pull up your map and Mark a new spot
yeah there's a couple houses along the
way we can aim for there might have some
walking to do
have the first person be only in the
least yeah I think it's on test server
but I don't think it's on the main thing
but I'm not entirely sure yeah it's here
no no but I mean first person only Oh
gotcha I don't think that's really [ __ ]
okay one of these checks I'm you know mo
while behind you you went ahead to the
markers and I'll catch up
yeah okay that was terrible on my part
dad drop uh you know I can you can go
first-person everyone so Michael Fisher
says God remember the Xbox one X will
give more balanced and stable gameplay
that's true but I think the big
advantage that PC will have is mouse and
keyboard but this is definitely but yeah
if you don't have a but I mean if you're
just playing other Xbox players and that
stability is pretty yeah alluring I
would agree sweet my afro is gone so
that's a good start I got a backpack
here we go I'm just gonna do you are
there people around you still no because
I'm gonna try to get some sort of weapon
before I meet up with you ooh
VSS is that the thirty or the nine mil
sniper I don't like it I can't
maybe I just suck with it which is very
very possible no all right here we go
got a stun grenade so look out everyone
so the no one dropped around here I
think I see a red dot on that picnic
table Oh ballistic mask do all right
here we go got a shock on an m16 holy
[ __ ] nice all routes have this yeah very
what it's a shack - so yeah I got the
scar in here that really not finished
the reload animation what the [ __ ] was
that that I hate when games do that I
mean I get why it doesn't complete the
animation it didn't register you
reloaded but if you clearly poke your
rounds into the weapon and then you
still have to do all right I'm gonna go
check out this octagon quick and then I
will have a red thought I gotta put on
as well I'm right up the hill from you
do you see me at all
damn dingo my favorite gun is the m16
I'm holding it right now so I'm feeling
good time will tell if I perform well so
he said you know I really like the 416
there's a 30 mm for sex RM 480 whatever
what the m416 the M is notice before
it's like the woman is shorter bear it's
like yeah that's yeah you could put more
attachments on that but it's not a long
range I would love like a to time square
just yet though I'm coming in your
billing I have hire me how many actually
no not five five six you have just 30 I
have one mag okay I can drop one for you
sweet did you check these outlying
buildings yet I checked one of them the
door will be open I've got some bandages
quick-draw mag in case I get Smeg cool I
am over in the circle actually here
there's another there's 30 gram mag
we're good okay we're gonna have to move
eventually but we're kind of set for now
at least as always I'll be the Czar that
gets us to go wait there's an m16 down
there was a scar I swapped mine oh sweet
all there's UMP [ __ ] should I go shotgun
or you have to I'll get you a P okay I'm
16 is best at medium short range yeah I
agree
yeah I never find this cars really good
the scar is really good the scar might
be my favorite don't want a shock on her
no I like the Yuppie I don't you should
get up here and pick up this I got some
other songs another red dot
yeah man I'm stuttering uh where's that
that's up here I'm up here it's in this
room right here sweet thank you dope
for this red dot on quick and vertical
foregrip quick drama egg or extended Meg
all right cool um I'm a decent shape I'd
like some body armor but we got a little
bit we can hang out here [ __ ] I'm not
closing doors behind you know we got to
be better about that cuz people know
we're here open doors and foot slapping
will give us away is this game on xbox
one not yet but it is coming what game
is this this is player unknowns
battlegrounds it is a hundred man how
did you get outside hundred man either
hundred person hundred yeah I'm just
look I said that cuz I'm looking at you
and you're and I'm a woman yeah you got
some sick haircut as opposed to my afro
um I haven't heard anything yet aside
from the bomb but you're dropping
Northwest I don't see anybody there's
gonna be people coming from [ __ ] yeah
I bet ya I'm kind of looking that way
right now but there's bombs so they're
not gonna be here anytime soon
oh man that like ledge cover physics
I gotta get crowbar so take that in case
you never know although the frying pan
is people will know can protect your
lower back if you're lucky
player unknowns battlegrounds yep that's
the one pub G is the game chicken dinner
is the aim yes it is we are gonna get a
chicken dinner today so well even if we
have to stream for six hours all right
we can run just wait to see what the
circle oh no we already know what the
start was gonna do no we don't it's
still I meant like I meant yes all right
I was like huh I mean we could get near
the bridge maybe I think we should wait
though
or we can at least move to these
buildings yeah yeah well I don't know
toward the road in case we need a jeep
want to do that Mike have you played war
of the chosen I can't wait no not yet
I've seen a lot of it I'm I cannot wait
either oh is it um yeah it's the
expansion people keep saying deal seeds
it's no it's an expansion revamp in the
game I can't wait we did a lobby chat
actually on our live show recently okay
I would love to talk about XCOM but I'm
gonna did give a body give a vest
I do [ __ ] can I have it
it's sandbox yeah I mean if my kids and
you can see the map it's I think it's 8
by 8 kilometers and it slowly shrinks as
you play I see you go with the campers
strategy game spot I mean not
necessarily last game we did on camping
last game we landed in the middle of
place if you call if you call running
across an open field camping then yeah
that's what we do immediately after
Smith with camp the bridge I think
honestly yeah that's the my strategy
depends on like the circle and where I
land in what I have yeah no I don't I we
actually I haven't been camping a lot
lately actually I'm just a full water
just yes get my doors seem closed get I
can hate this
yeah doors are closed are probably good
here unless they're smart like we should
have been our closing them now there's
too much stuff here
close the doors behind you though those
the outside doors that's well that's
what I mean there's your refusal to
alright [ __ ] yeah
car 98 what do I keep though my m16 yeah
this probably isn't the best weapon
combo actually but I'll do it I need a
if you find a good scope let me news the
volume low for anyone else I turn the
volume about as high as it can mic you
might want to go in your settings and
turn it up though because I may have had
it pretty low no 100% it may just
because there's no action happening
right now
yeah but do I want this car right now
waiting for a car yeah where have you
been yeah do I need a better scope
though cuz I have an m16 in a car I'm
not giving up my m16 to my baby alright
let's find you a scope I mean I have oh
I don't even have a handgun yeah I don't
think do the weapons feel balanced
haven't played much great because it's
PC to be honest I don't really know I
feel like I haven't had enough
interactions to be honest like really
judge it it's kind of hard to even say
whether they're balanced because like
usually I just so random that you'll
actually go up against some of the same
exact yeah class of weapon they're all
good for something different like I
actually like the feel of the m16 as
opposed to the scar personally someone
said car 98 they're excited you got it
Eric damn dude I found him tomorrow
here's a holographic sight that would be
fantastic I'll pick it up after a
[ __ ] car though I don't think I can
do a holographic on a car do you hear
that no I think that's a plane I think
we're good scare me
sweet you got a better backpack there's
another UMP here if you want it I'm
nervous and I don't have anything like
automatic because when push comes to
shove I hate I can do this bike actually
Coco cuckoo-land excellent get shape - I
don't have any first aid that's what's
worrying me I don't think I do either
I've upstairs already you're any
different building now yeah do you need
see what's going on out here for a
second most likely come from the
northwest right not this side pan yeah
if you find any you get a holographic
you said right I'll come get that you're
up the hill I'm coming this is actually
where they a lot of people would likely
be coming from have you gone in here I
know I don't want to do that outside you
drop it alright alright going inside
yeah I'm stuck I thank you
would be better to have an for variable
scope are they're very oh I agree
um actually I don't know I'm just saying
I want a better scope in a holographic
for sure this will do for now come on
there's more building Illinois let's uh
yeah we could go up the road a little
bit
rather than we have quite a bit of time
circle move oh we're outside a circle
dome now how far are we not too far
any winds yet today no I come here first
got one yesterday I just marked yellow
you want to move there first rather than
go into the circle right away we got
three of us move yeah Jake I won
yesterday you know checking on his
Twitter pretty intense in terms of
network lag while he was shooting the
last dude the guy threw a Molotov was
about to hit me in the face if I could
if I killed him in E later I would've
died or if I didn't kill him right then
I would have that I guess oh there's a
gun on this ticket nope never mind sorry
he knows if you hold shift that goes
times - yes I guess I'll take that I
guess I'll take that can't hurt
oh well oh you're in there yeah sorry
all right order yellow yeah now the
don't even know if that's variable I
guess ship just holding your breath
almost in terms of like other games
it doesn't actually it does help those
studies it
we need healing stuff I don't have any I
have bandages that's it
which let's be honest telling you is not
probably the most us maybe the most
underrated I mean like the energy drink
is probably my most I would say the most
underrated item and this is someone says
I have so many things to say yeah
everybody will always have many pups
dreams yeah there's a lot of pub streams
yeah but yeah we're probably doing
things differently a lot of other people
which I guess it's always learning but
oh here's body armor I'll come grab that
a second 12 yeah if you'd like those
can't be too careful what's in the
building I was just in on the new the
the table with dining table okay why do
you pick up unnecessary attachments why
Mike why what that's all I thought I had
and I've said alright how did the ump
before I guess I could ditch these could
call times to scope yes thank you I'll
take that in a second is that the same
building you're in already
no okay I'm there so I'm not really
paying attention to anything going on
could hang out here until the circle is
about to close down were actually a good
position sorry uh armor wasn't what I
wasn't paying attention to what house
you're right well no armor for you then
two times in here is it's in this
building over here
where's the two times go I have it no I
can drop it let's let me take a
holographic sight though then okay just
head over to me oh these doors but
you're gonna get us killed just check-in
sure know what's sneaking up on us
fifteen times them insane I've seen the
solo players when that's it easy I've
never even seen a 15-times I've seen a
couple of eight times I know there's
such a thing all right what are you
doing I'm just checking where's the body
armor you mission here's times to scope
here's body all right close these doors
all right cool
and then keep dropping oh you're a McGee
there you go all right we're in good
shape I feel better and I have armor
which is good okay yeah this game seems
tailor-made for screaming because
unpredictability and you can kind of
like there's a thought process involved
which I'm not always I don't know I say
we could wait a little longer
we're pretty close oh wait we should get
some a better position though like here
this little Hut on the side of the road
yeah that's gonna close in on the bridge
I think
which sucks hey I guess let's get into
it
should we try to find a boat now I see a
boat
should we just get to the other side now
should we just wait by the boat he'll
try to get it okay I go for the boat the
world will go from there you say you saw
people door Oh CD yeah he does have door
OCD yeah well everybody calls it OCD
until you this game is all preparation
son Oh shet people on the boat it's gone
wait all right what are the odds way
hold on no I'm not gonna get them all
right let's go these ones Oh
can I go over here yeah I didn't mean to
run right into you in the middle
the odds are gonna run the people in
these houses somewhat high if this goes
down the bridge it's gonna go on the
bridge it has to what are you guys
running for setting seems to run and
look well there one the one might just
Klingon I'm pretty sure that's set for
the highest setting in the one I'm doing
I'm not entirely sure this isn't mine
but you can't see mine anyway
[ __ ] right I hear gunshots to the left
there's some open doors - oh [ __ ] you're
ahead of me hold ups you're good
I've got to the left I don't hear that
[ __ ] that's near me it it was yeah I
hear him - sham coming
it's like northeast okay
[Music]
we got it across to get should we just
start talking I guess
just get ready to dive stay on to the
bridge like last time this happened
yeah damn I haven't seen anybody aside
from those dudes in the boat [ __ ] dude
this is not good we're on opening makes
it a lot easier to always be into the
top 10 yes it does the rear I don't like
this at all we don't really have a
choice though I guess we just see your
point this one here under the bridge I
would rather do under the bridge you
don't have a whole lot of time left
though yeah I mean at least the bridge
will be able to alright
someone said airdrop airdrop oh it's way
over there
restricting the player in one minute
yeah just swim under the bridge we'll be
good I read that far from circle is it
on the opposite bank yet no it's not
quite there okay yeah we find just
standard of the bridge I don't
understand the easiest way to cross a
bridge or the safe straight across
bridges to swim underneath it or the
people on the bridge can't see you boat
yeah it's gonna be some great
live-streaming
well we can check chat now guys watch
the outcome of footage from eight months
ago this game looks amazing compared to
how the out flips I'm sure it does I
mean I think it looks pretty good it's
more of just like it runs kind of game
yeah Jake obviously stick close to the
bridge as possible
you are act in real life you'd be in an
advantage without shoes on when you're
swimming as opposed to my punk boots
with spikes on them so I'm going faster
love the beach run 0x given I know for
the record I was nervous about it
damn dude I will make it but this is
gonna be boring yeah it'll be fun when
we gets the opposite bank unless we just
get out and die yeah yeah Oh gunshots
going under
all right back down here so uh I got a
ballistics mask so my face is pretty
good those are close yes they are it's a
car it's probably someone camped on the
bridge so Jake please please I came over
to the left I don't know oh [ __ ] I just
lost health that was dumb sure the
gunshots kind of freaked out pretty far
out there
oh you're going to circle I see whoa
okay bring it won't go
hey what long no I know I'm just trying
circles right behind us
oh [ __ ] oh no not [ __ ] this guy I don't
have an energy drink either I don't
think Oh God
man this circle sucked okay coming up
for air quick
it's [ __ ] if he kills me serpentine if
the circle doesn't kill me this guy's
going to go go go you'll make it you'll
make it oh I'll make it but it's it's
the circle hole
oh thank you so much James big Mack that
helps so much that diet this diving with
C as opposed to looking poppy think
waiting farther go go go go people on
the beach straight ahead of us at 150
you see that like literally at the end
of we're gonna fight them as soon as we
get there you see what I mean yeah dude
right under the bridge get in get in and
stop hurting me I gotta heal as soon as
we get there if I get the chance someone
died in the water where I can see a
floating box don't actually [ __ ] look
see if you get first aid and give it to
me all right dudes right on the beach
I'm just gonna get in the circle
and go to the under the bridge right now
that's cool with you
cuz there's there are guys on the cliff
right at the there on the cliff on the
left side of the beach over kind of at
150 still I hate when I'm chasing the
circle look how many boats pulled up
here oh my gosh I'm gonna have to do
some man of which were ours alright he's
still on the cliff I can peg him once I
get up onto land he's still on the cliff
yeah so he's at 150 on the bank going up
to the bridge he's right on it he's kind
of just like hovering there cuz people
see him I hope he doesn't see me [ __ ] I
think he sees me god damn it I don't see
him he's right at 150 he's shooting at
you [ __ ] hold on second I'm going
down [ __ ] you're dead nice shooting Mike
[ __ ] I missed him like 19 times can you
check the map do I have time to bandage
bandaging wounds heal under water you
can heal under water I didn't know that
neither did I that would have been
useful to know but like I was saying one
of the most underrated items is the
energy drink because it heals over time
you could pop it like when you know
you're gonna be in a bad situation as a
preventive thing I don't have that right
now which sucks all right let's see if
should have healed I know I well I had
full health when we first started all
right there's a box right here [ __ ] what
do I need still like first-aid right
like that's my one thing I don't have
[ __ ] come on nothing
level three helmet at this point would
that be worth it yeah yeah yeah I guess
so
two times scope on my m16 as well maybe
[ __ ] no I don't think so
to time scope do I want that you circle
about to move again
alright thank you how far [ __ ]
this is gonna be great only 14 left
though yeah I killed no one saw no one
this guy have four times scope [ __ ] yeah
let's do that holographic do I want a
holographic instead of a two times four
machine no no there we go
flashhider it's better than nothing wait
did he have first aid
yeah holy [ __ ] II a lot of bandages
anything else no I gotta go yeah
[ __ ] I don't want to go up here only
twelve alive don't go up there I should
go right oh you see that guy out there I
got this all right I'm so worried about
this bridge and how many people are
likely okay I see this guy see if I can
find him where'd he go he's going
through the buildings like a smart
person you are on the fence there he is
there he is you see
oh and one more [ __ ] you jumped it what
an [ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta go right I don't
have time for this you're gonna run into
him again I bet yeah I'm just [ __ ] I'm
taking the long way round I think it's
worth it I probably could do another
bandage right now if I wanted to but we
know you can't if your Health's white
you can't [ __ ] good point sorry I keep
forgetting all my energy drinks we did a
number on that dude I feel I feel like
it would have killed him if I'd that
second if he didn't jump over that
second bullet like I was saying you left
105 five six rounds behind [ __ ] that's
one thing I wasn't looking out for damn
alright well keep it a mental note don't
do that again
[ __ ] yeah check come here oh no no no I
don't know yeah I don't know if the
circle will cut that way oh I just saw
him I just got stick along this cliff
here those five five six rounds not
getting those is gonna kill me no
he's way up there I gotta get in the
circle before I start shooting at him oh
[ __ ] yeah that circle is I got it
but also yeah that's gonna kill me later
not having those rounds for ya that
dudes not gonna be in the circle but I
also need cover really badly
alright good thing the circle did not
hurt me yeah I know I'm I wanted to put
my gun away but I didn't need to at this
point so I'm not going to [ __ ] should I
be worried about this dude [ __ ]
[ __ ] a peg them box holy bleep
don't don't oh wait another guy behind
there out of circles I don't work with
steps by you [ __ ] oh damn it I shouldn't
have worried about those guys I'm sure
they just [ __ ] got into the circle
and waited all right whatever
ah that was an uneventful game president
yeah no yeah I just did not feel come
from putting my gun away I probably
should have been better about that that
time
oh man all right what time is it
12:01 do one more yeah unless it's like
a press drop let's no let's drop in
somewhere some like somewhere busy let's
just get right into it but then we're
gonna die soon
yeah well it's like noon right now okay
yeah I just don't want it to be boring
again cuz I was boring I don't know got
a lot of viewers yeah I don't care yeah
let's just let's just do a field right
we don't have to purposely die soon but
[ __ ] dude
I wasn't dude there was like three
people outside that circle I was in good
shape I just kept running
that was better they were like bad
judgment on my part locked in a fight I
think they're all at the point where
they were trying to get kills for the
experience and they knew they were dead
yeah [ __ ] that guy right next to me
honestly like the one the most important
thing in this game is usually
positioning yeah well that's how we won
we just like dude yeah getting to the
right side of the circle and like coming
in from the side and no one else is
gonna be but yeah I also miss all that
five five six ammo for the flash
inevitable showdown with the last few
people if I made it that far which I
didn't so it doesn't matter
try the military tony's military toner
so cool I've only like been in um once
though so what the military tunnels okay
this is the most tense this game gets
final ten
yeah that's it's two tents that's not no
this is not kind of whoops quants that
Hut think people leap off the plane is
fine there's that floating plane over in
the water - I can't read the name to
move far away but this is the best way
to learn how to shoot is to jump into a
hot zone and start having after that's
definitely best way to get better at
schemes to actually get in combat um
it's going to be coming from the north
all right Roger shock yeah all right or
that swamp town that we always start in
like around here actually swamp town
just walk down all right because I feel
like a lot of if there's gonna be a lot
of people that there's this whomp down
there
all right let's drop now
I'll do the swim just because apparently
it's it helps
I just
when does it come out for Xbox one in
the fall no exact release date yet
unfortunately which way where were you
gonna go specifically let's go right to
that swamp town yeah I guess I'm gonna
go these buildings on the edge to see
run got people that check correct me if
I'm wrong but this is the fast way to
drop right to spiral and then just go
straight down should I drop or should I
not I would yeah there's four buildings
will probably have decent loot
I don't know if anybody else I mean I
think I'm alone you're not alone there's
two other people I just saw not like
right next to you but there in the swamp
toes alright I mean I'll try to get
something decent so I can come and help
you out or if you need it or cover you
I'm not gonna worry about kill everyone
so nothing nothing nothing energy drink
so one thing I didn't have last time and
then that do you hose me with a a K or
whatever he had nothing nothing nothing
damn I got a car nice sorry not a car 98
but a vehicle the best [ __ ] I don't
think I've seen any like anything got a
sickle sweet guess I'll pull that out in
case
at last building here I'm gonna check
out and then I can come over to you well
we're in perfect position we're on the
right on the edge of the circle and by
that I mean people will probably start
streaming in here nothing
[ __ ] all right I'm going upstairs quick
what's your loot situation like so you
got shotgun the shotgun and a pistol
backpack not great but not uh all right
I got some here we go so P 1911 got some
bandages
I'm not tabbing this because I don't got
shitty though I need a backpack
I'll take it a helmet all right it's
better than nothing uh I'll try to scope
it out I don't see dude there's
literally no there were no weapons aside
from handguns over here but we look good
in terms of people I'm gonna come over
toward vehicle I think your your area is
big enough I'll find something
inevitably in terms of weaponry the
Glock let me bring the car over to you
we are kind of like right on the edge
you think it's worth bringing the car
yeah bring people here there are
definitely people here I'll get it
closest oh you got a clock that was in a
recent update right
[ __ ] you don't like come on in here [ __ ]
this is bad I'll be over here Carl
oh [ __ ] no I'm gonna leave it near the
road do you see where I am I'm gonna try
to kind of hide it here I sincerely hope
they must hear me but or you could
potentially shoot into a building and
try to hurt people I didn't know that
either because that's happened several
times where okay just door being open
makes me nervous and the fact there's no
loo unless you came in here I probably
came in there let me see yeah
I checked that building - okay
[ __ ] she had a side with Miss Hannigan
I'm gonna seem you check this one or
maybe not
yeah I think you know unless you didn't
get this handgun how do I know have a
backpack yet what the [ __ ] I think it
looks like you're in this building check
upstairs anyway just in case
I don't see anybody else yet I haven't
seen anyone else are there we're still
right on the edge you definitely want
this building or someone did
I'm gonna swim over there you still
shotgun still the best thing you have
yep thing to go over to these buildings
have you gone over here yet these ones
I'm looking at out across about I get so
nervous when I haven't seen anybody for
a while and I know I'm right on the edge
of the circle I guess that's the game
a sniper rifle cheek pad which is super
useful and you don't have a sniper I can
find a goddamn weapon he saw me he got
me down are you serious what do you hit
you with wait no back up I'll come over
to you were you that I'll dude you're
right in the middle no you're not wait
yeah you are quick where's yet he's he's
way out he's not gonna be an issue well
he just hit you just get up here and lay
down you'll be fine
I can't revive you from laying down well
I mean just you can Crouch you'll be
fine yeah up there
that was stupid of me
[ __ ] dude are you sure he's not gonna
did you shoot yeah I did sorry get
inside alright [ __ ] dude I do this look
like I can open the door now no like I
have to hold on hold on give me a second
I can't do anything what the [ __ ] is he
I don't either
where is yet I know but if I get up he's
gonna get behind these boxes but tell me
where he is like we'll give me a number
he's to the west but alright oh my gonna
try to die dude
I both gonna die like what one more do
you want me to do I'm getting you oh god
is right there that was stupid I
shouldn't have done that
he was right next week
did I shouldn't there was nothing more I
could've done more
alright alright
uh-oh I can't do anything keep flirting
well dude if I can loot when I'm prone I
can't revive you when I'm prone it would
have made me stand up or go crouched
let's do one more
the one more stream begins yeah there's
an m16 right next you don't know if you
saw that too
no I I went over there and saw it again
anything he saw me and I had a I had a
bone arrow right a crossbow and I was
like maybe I can hit him from out here
no I know I just saying I don't know if
you saw the m16 on the ground next to
you that in the a K we're next to you I
have waiting for Jake the fresh oh why
am I not wearing clothes now he just
like left the server or something and I
need to refresh
okay Wow no more small town all right
it's ready up and then [ __ ] get this
chicken dinner haven't announced on ps4
I imagine once they want to but yeah
once it like fully comes out cuz right
now ps4 can't do like a preview or early
access program like the Xbox but I
imagine once it's once it's fully out
there probably you can see you all the
server's yeah I was thinking about that
after I thought I should have not forged
into that room I also could have hoped
the door phone which is what you were
saying but I also had no idea where the
guy was why not dude we could go nude
I'm all mixed in one of us
right
where's Tay with the wrap it up box
for [ __ ]
you know how about
Gatka okay that's not even really a big
town you know here's not but we're here
cars and [ __ ] or the coast
yes sure I'm down the coast look for a
car or Yakka let's do this
yes farm lands
thank you here in Patel and thank you
for the tips all right let's drop this
is play oh yeah oh man this must be so
liberating to drop without any clothes
on
cool
so people in the Czech correct me if I'm
not doing it right but people tell me
this gets you farther like sort of
shadow a need to worry about that right
now that's out there is looks like is a
guys falling with this
where
don't see
I see him yeah I'm bellowing though I'm
gonna get there and just [ __ ] I'm
belong to all right I'm gonna go there's
a couple of them I'm gonna get in
there's a two storey to storey blue
roofed house is the one I'm going into
or if you want spread out and find guns
and okay I got when I go in you got a
gun already yep it's a handgun but it's
something I'm trying to find a sec well
you right here yeah okay well this doors
open already there's a guy in there he's
probably got a guy with me with me no
he's in this one right here come over
here come over here
oh the red house okay I'm coming oh [ __ ]
yep I see him you got a helmet and
[ __ ] backpack oh [ __ ]
all right he okay I'm get I got a
handgun I got something to defend myself
with I've got enough not much I don't
want to [ __ ] close I've got a UMP
suppressor [ __ ] yeah you got a UMP
that's better than what I have all right
where is this douchebag he's still in
that house you saw him and I believe
well I should be able to see him he was
in this red house on the southwest side
you know I mean you saw I think he's
still in there actually don't quote me
on that be careful oh [ __ ] I see you let
me know if he's in there cuz I can I got
I got an angle on the windows I don't
see him in there but I'm not gonna go
inside and find out I think he's in the
bathroom
he's not on I don't see him on this side
I think I think he's in the bathroom
I see the bathroom I think like the blue
tile wall I don't see anybody
oh I don't seem in there alright let me
try a building with you okay well I
could just come help you out with him I
just got to find something better than I
don't know where he is though that's the
thing okay let me see if I can
oh [ __ ] wait [ __ ] it's a chair maybe he
left door was open maybe he did there's
a shotgun in here
no ammo though which makes me think he
may if all the doors are closed
yeah oh okay people in the cornfield
over at 3:45 not a huge deal at all
we are all so we're gonna have to move
soon it for the circle in a little bit
unless you see a car here right that guy
go he probably got that [ __ ] and ran to
get in the circle right or he's in the
bathroom like I suspected nice oh [ __ ]
what did he died was there someone with
him he's there's someone with him yeah
wait right near you I have no idea but
he got down you mean he is down ok um he
was in the bathroom like I suspected but
in a different building alright um I
don't I have no idea where to go okay
I'm coming over I'll try to dude I have
a handgun that's all keep in mind hey
you got a shirt now yeah I didn't mean
to I'm gonna take that off in a second
when I get the time I just
oh I didn't know I should be working as
a team oh all right
go first stuff all right least we're
here now cool he's got a factor if you
want that yeah please if you don't mind
I'll take it
actually you you uh sort through that
stuff out and a watch I see the shock
I'm gonna get that quick give me a
12-gauge close this door quick then we
got to move soon I will definitely take
that vector kind of ammo is vector
[ __ ] even have a backpack do you have
one he did and I took it because I
needed oh you know okay cool I need more
ammo I don't have any I need help I'm
gonna drop this 9-millimeter honestly
right now for the 45 ammo we need to go
go go
let me get this I don't have enough
space for that either [ __ ] we need to go
I know I don't I don't have a mo for
this all right let's just go I guess I
don't really have anything else on move
yeah um let's go [ __ ] you where's that
other dude I don't know I didn't see
anybody else but okay I see him I see
him okay double back on um I gotta he is
behind the house we just came from
on the other side the Red House you want
to go left I'll go right
yeah all right go right let me stay
behind his wall he had some sort of
long-range weapon I think but keep an
eye Oh God see I'm shot from over here
where you bet they're shooting from the
south okay you see if I could find this
guy first okay I see this guy there's
another guy oh is that the guy you
already right next to this dude can you
see behind scars guy right behind his
car right there
not yeah front of you get to him [ __ ]
I'll lure him over here he's rep on your
right behind scar literally crouched
right here see him yeah he's moving up
he's move up behind a dumpster I'm right
here
see him he just knocked me down Fox one
else shoot us that was a dumb game to
end on yeah whatever cool all right well
I'm gonna call it for the day no but
yeah I know I want to keep playing
unfortunately yeah we're out of time
okay all right we're gonna be playing
next Monday we'll be playing in the
meantime so maybe we can be better at
not dying as much I have fun I had fun
as well but yeah we'll play will be
playing battlegrounds again on Monday
make sure to check out reboot I'm gonna
switch the camera so you can see our
beautiful faces but make sure to check
out reboot we just had a new episode all
about this game actually so if you are
enjoying this game I definitely
recommend checking it out I would have
gone Auto on the vector if I didn't have
13 rounds yeah although on the vector
can be rough but I was on single but I
would have gone Auto to killin because
but I had 13 rounds so it's like yeah
cool planer nose battlegrounds we have
streams everyday at 11:00 tomorrow I'm
not sure what destiny 2 will be the
stream tomorrow the beta will be up as
of tomorrow the full beta I think I
think for people who pre-ordered on ps4
cool yeah so stick around for that stuff
as always just so I will have streams
every day at 11 and
yeah thanks for stopping by and we'll
see you tomorrow thank you guys
[ __ ] that last guy with a shotgun